- The loser of this game—
- Yes?
- Has to eat these hot wings that are comin’ out.
- I’m wit it.
- What’s up, everybody? It’s your boy
Meech, and I’m in Chicago.
Tonight, I’ll be hangin’ with
my man Karl-Anthony Towns.
We’re gonna bowl a few games,
and we’re gonna play NBA 2K on
Google’s new gaming platform, Stadia,
where you can game anywhere, anytime.
Let’s go meet up with KAT.
- What up, bro?
- What’s up, KAT?
Thanks for comin’ to bowl with me.
- Absolutely.
- Here’s your controller.
- Which one? That one?
- Yes, sir.
- OK.
- I already plugged in the Chromecast.
They got Wi-Fi, so we’re good to go.
- Oh, we lit.
- Yeah, bro.
Before we get to the lanes,
let’s play some 2K and then—
I’mma beat you in this, and then I’mma beat you on that.
- Psh, I don’t know about that, but we’ll see.
- What team you gonna use?
- With the cameras around, I guess I’ll pick Minnesota.
- You gonna pick yourself? All right.
- How do you change uniforms? You hit Y?
- You wanna change uniforms? Yeah, hit Y.
- Oooh, OK!
- Yeah.
All right, let’s get it.
You still rockin’ the sleeve?
- I used to. I had a elbow thing—
- Uh-huh.
- So I was, like, rockin’ it to protect it,
but I think it do look swaggy.
Oh, got ‘em.
- That’s how you start it?
- No, I thought—
- What do you usually do, you know,
on your days off to unwind?
- Wow. Uh, usually, I like bowling with friends, but
I always like, you know, just, really, playin’ video games.
You know, golfing, just really doin’—
- Golf?!
- Yeah, I love golfing, man.
- How’s all the traveling been treating you?
- That’s probably the most challenging thing that has
been for me in the NBA is just the travel. It’s nonstop.
- What do you do to keep up with it?
- Hope to God my phone works.
I ain’t gonna lie, these graphics is crazy.
- Clean, right?
And the greatest thing about it too—
- Wow!
- You can game anywhere as long as you got Wi-Fi.
- I know, and that’s crazy.
Cuz if you told me I could just have this and I don’t need
anything else, that saves a lotta space in the luggage.
- Nooo.
- Oh, my God!
- No!
- Oh! Come in, Karl!
Goddamn!
- Nooo.
- Sheesh.
As long as 32’s on the court, I feel pretty
confident in my, in my ability to win.
- What’s, like, the one thing that, I guess,
you were kinda skeptical about with Stadia that
you see is, you know, this is the real deal?
- It’s the graphics more.
- Mhm.
- I feel like it was more the graphics cuz I knew with
my gaming experience—like, PC, but I didn’t know, like,
could it really pull it off?
- Yeah, for sure.
- And, like, it really does.
I’m a guy who’s been playin’ console controller
for years and just to see, like,
the controller itself is actually very nice to have.
- I mean, I’m gonna show you some crazier things
after we finish bowling, but—
Oooh, sauce him up!
But this is literally just beginning, man.
Thank you!
- That was a good move, Will!
- Let’s bowl some.
Oh, sh—
- There you go.
- See what I’m workin’ with?
- A little left.
- Got any tips for me?
- Go straight.
- OK.
I got a challenge for you.
Next person that gets a strike is the winner.
- OK.
- Loser has to finish the half with their eyes closed.
- All right, bet.
Jeez!
Uh-oh!
- Yes!
- For the nation!
- Do I match it now?
- Match it.
Sick.
- Say less!
Oooh. I just threw the sexiest dot to Willie.
What happened to 32?
- I can’t see 32. That’s the problem.
I don’t even know if I got the ball.
- Nah, you got the ball now.
You have the ball. YOU have the ball. You’re not—
you’re in the backcourt, though. Press A.
Pass it up, pass it—this man just shot a full-court shot!
- There you go.
- You’re dribblin’ to the paint right now, but you got a
defender on you. Pass. Jumper. Fade. Miss.
- This announcing is just amazing. Just—
Oh, I’m still up. Oh, good.
- Yeah, you still up.
- It’s lit.
- All right, KAT. Let’s hit pause on this, man.
I’m gettin’ a little hungry.
Let’s pick the game up at the bar.
I got the Pixel here for you.
- OK.
- We’re gonna just connect it right here.
- There we go.
- You can take this one. Plug it in, man.
Pick it up right where we left off.
- This is actually ridiculous.
This is the most impressive thing cuz
the graphics are just as good still.
What is happening?
- That’s the thing that really gets me.
I'm essentially still on console.
- Yeah.
- Come on, hit him! Oh, my goodness!
- No way.
- Hey, you better hit that too.
- Oh, my goodness!
Get busy!
All right, I got one last challenge for you.
- OK.
- The loser of this game—
- Yes.
- Has to eat these hot wings that are comin’ out.
- I’m wit it.
- Do you have any big goals
before the end of the season?
Anything else you’re tryna accomplish or just things
you wanna accomplish in the next couple years?
- I don’t know. I’mma see where life takes me.
- Mhm.
- I’m not really worried about the future yet
because I gotta worry about the present
to set it up, you know?
- That’s absolutely true.
- You know what I’m tryna say?
- I’m a confirmed bucket.
I’m a confirmed—mmm.
- I’ll tell you who’s a confirmed bucket: that man.
- That man?
- That man.
Where the wings at?
- Here we go, guys. Hot wings.
- This is hot with a H-A-W-T or H-O-T?
- Eh, hit it.
- Hot is hot.
- It's spicy.
- It cool?
- It’s one of them that hits you late.
Yo, I appreciate you comin’ out with me,
bowling a lil’ bit, playin’ some 2K.
- Yes, sir.
- To get your own—
- Yeah.
- Go to stadia.com, get your Stadia Premiere Edition.
- All right. Say less.
- All right, man.
- My G.
- Yes, sir. Good luck!
- Appreciate you. Appreciate you, man.
But there’s more wings over here,
so you gotta go finish those.
- Ohhh.